لنفهم ما الذي يجري ايضا من الناحيه
العسكريه ينضم الينا من عمان اللواء فايز
الدويل الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي مما استمعت اليه من مراسلنا
حصان مسعود ومن الهجمات التي وقعت بالامس
37 صاروخ مجنح كروز
وهجوم غير مسبوق بطائرات مسيره على عدي في
دوناتس في العاصمه كييف كيف كيف نفهم
هذا التصعيد من الجانب الروسي في مثل هذه
الهجمات لسيمه بالصواريخ ودعنا نتذكر انه
هذا الهجوم بالصواريخ ياتي بعد ما اعلنت
سلطات كييف ان الروسي يستخدمون المسيرات
اكثر لان
مخزونهم من الصواريخ اخذهم في النفاذ
يعني هو عاده يقال
هدوء ما قبل العاصفه ولكن انا اقول تصعيد
ما قبل العاصفه الان العاصفه الطبيه هنا
الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني الذي كثر الحديث
عنه وقال انتظاره وبالتالي كان لابد من
وتزامن مع تصعيد اوكراني بدءا من قصف
الكرملين بالطائرات المسيره مرورا
متعدد في شبه جزيره القرم قصف ماريوبل
مهاجمه بيلو قرود واخلاق تسعه بلدات منها
واخلاق مستودع للرؤوس النوويه اذا هذا
التصعيد وهذا التشبع في التحضير وارتفاع
سقف الحديث عن هجوم مضاد واسع النطاق
يستلزم من وجهه نظر عسكريه بحته ان يكون
هناك
مقابل
يختار الاهداف بدقه في ابعادها السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه والعسكريه من اجل اجهاض
الهجوم او تاجيل وقت شن الهجوم او تقليل
واضعاف قدرات القوات التي تم تحبيرها لهذا
الهجوم لهذا السبب العمليات العسكريه
فخاصه في الحرب العالميه الثانيه عندما
كان يتم التحضير لهجوم الكورسك او
ستالينغراد او لينينغراد وغير ذلك كانت
الفتره السابقه على ساعه الصفر هي فتره
تصاعد محموم في العمليات والعمليات
المضاده لهذا السبب انا كانسان اقول
التاريخ العسكري لا يمكن القفز من فوقه
هذا الامر يجب ان يكون من قبل دوائر صنع
القرار في كلا الجانبين الجانب الاوكراني
يصعد ليكون عاملا مساعدا لانجاح الهجوم
والجانب الروسي يصعب من اجل اجهاض هذا
تصعيد الجانب الاوكراني كما ذكرت او
الدخول على خط المواجهه بشكل مختلف هذه
المره ما مدى قدرته على التصدي لاي
سيناريو قادم
الان الحديث فيما قبل هجوم الربيع فهي في
الفتره السابقه او الفتره التحضيريه لهذا
الهجوم الجانبي يعني لا يمكننا ان نعتمد
البيانات القادمه من من كلا الطرفين كانها
حقائق دامغه لانه كل جانب يضخم من
انجازاته الجانب الاوكراني يتحدث عن اسقاط
تقريبا 67 هدف جوي بينما الاهداف الجويه
اذا تتبعنا الارقام عددها 63 بمعنى اخر
اسقط اكثر من العدد الذي تم الحديث عنه في
الجانب الروسي كذلك نفس الشيء اذا الخبر
اليقين او القرين من الحقيقه ياتي لاحقا
من قبل وكالات الاستخبارات الغربيه رغم
يتهمها البعض بالتحيز وما شابه ذلك لكن
دعيني اقول بصوره دقيقه هذا التصعيد
سيستمر
القدرات الاوكرانيه قياسا على الحديث
الاوكراني في بعض الحالات وصلت نسبه اسقاط
المسيرات والصواريخ الى مئه بالمئه في
معظم الحالات كانت اعلى من 90% مما حدث
الرئيس الاوكراني ان يشكر العناصر العامله
بالدفاع الجوي لكن وينسب الاضرار الى حطام
الصواريخ والطائرات لكن دعيني اقول لا
يزال للدفاع الجوي الاوكراني يعاني لماذا
لتنوع الاهداف ووسائل استخدام هذه الاهداف
عندما نتحدث عن المسجد بين الطائرات
المسيره والصواريخ هذا المزج مردد جدا
للدفاعات الجويه هو يبعث الطائرات في
البدايه تعمل بطاريات الدفاع الجوي تبدا
يفعل
محطات الرادار وشبكات الرادار تبدا
النبضات الرادريه بالانطلاق اجهزه
المراقبه والرصد تحدد هذه المواقع ياتي
الهجوم بالصواريخ الفرد الصوتيه سواء كان
كنجال او اسكندر او ما شابه ذلك فبالتالي
لابد ان تتجاوز بعض هذه الصواريخ منظومات
الدفاع الجوي ومجرد سقوط صاروخ من صواريخ
اسكندر او فنجان على هدف عسكري او
استراتيجي سيلحق اغراض باهظه
صواريخ كنجال وصواريخ اسكندر صواريخ باهضه
التكلفه في حين ان طائرات شاهد الانتحاريه
تكلفتها بسيطه
ما هي الاستراتيجيه الروسيه هل هل
الصواريخ التي تطلق تطلق هل يمكن
الاستمرار في هذا هذه الاستراتيجيه قابله
للاستمرار ثم ايضا من جانب الدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه وهي تستخدم منظومات
القليله التي لديها هل هي قادره على
الاستمرار ايضا في التصدي للصواريخ
يعني
بالجانب الاوكراني يوجد بطاريتين بطاريه
من امريكا وبطاريه من المانيا وتم الحديث
قبل ثلاثه اسابيع على
الجانب الروسي قال تدمير والجانب
الاوكراني ومن ثم لاحقا
قيل
اضرار وانا تحدثت بذلك اليوم وقلت لا يمكن
لصاروخ فنجال ان يدمر بطاريه
كامله لانها تتكون من سته اجزاء توضيعها
متباعد وهناك مسافات بينيه يمكن ان يدمر
الاطلاق يمكن ان يرد دمر شبكه الرادار
يمكن ان يدمر نظام المراقبه نتحدث الان
فقط
لان القوات الاوكرانيه القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن هجوم جديد تتعرض له
العاصمه كييف استخدمت فيه الصواريخ
البالستيه
طبعا هذا بعد
بعدما افادم رسولنا بسلسله انفجارات قويه
في العاصمه الاوكرانيه وانفجار صواريخ
ايضا في سماء المدينه الان القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه تقول انه هجوما جديدا تتعرض له
العاصمه كيف استخدمت فيه الصواريخ
الباليستيه
يا سيدي انا قلت في البدايه تصعيد ما قبل
العاصفه وقلت ان ان دائره توسيع الاهداف
وكثافه الهجوم متوقع ان تزداد حده قلت ذلك
قبل صدور هذا الخبر العاجل لان الامر من
وجهه نظر عسكريه امر حتمي لابد لروسيا اذا
ارادت ان تجهض الهجوم الاوكراني او ان
تؤخره او ان تحد من قدراته لابد لها ان
تصاعد وتختار الاهداف بعنايه انت الطائرات
المسيره والثمن البسيط
والتكلفه الباهظه لصواريخ الفرد صوتيه او
صواريخ الباترول باك 3 يصل في بعض
القراءات الى ثلاثه ملايين الدلع الان في
من حيث الصواريخ الفرد الصوتيه من الجانب
الروسي لاحظ الان هي تاتي في معظم الحالات
لا اقول جميعا تاتي في معظم الحالات بعد
الهجوم الطائرات المسيره لعده عوامل منها
عوامل تقنيه حسابيه رياضيه
عوامل لانجاح العمل كما قلت قبل قليل ان
يتم تحديد اماكن شبكات وبطاريات ويتم
بالتالي
الان ما هو المخزون الروسي لا احد يستطيع
ان يقرر ولكن كمخطط في القيام في هيئه
الاركان العليا الروسيه يفترض به ان يكون
لديه بنك معلومات كامل حول موجوداته
وطريقه استخدامها وكثافه استخدامها وطبيعه
الاهداف الان لا يمكن ان اطلق صاروخ تكلفه
اربعه
مليون دولار على طائره
126 شاهد الا في حاله ان هذه الطائره
ملتزمه
فقط الى هذا العاجل الحاكم بالجرودوسيه
يتحدث عن سقوط اربع ضحايا في القصف
الاوكراني الذي استهدف مؤسستين صناعيتين
في المقاطعه
ما مدى الترابط بينما يجري في بيلج حاليا
وما يجري في كيا فكنت قد تحدثت عن تصعيد
متوقع او قصف ما قبل التصعيد او قبل
العاصفه ولكن ما حدود هذا التصعيد في
تقديرك عسكري
يعني لفت انتباهي في هذا اليوم تصريح
لحاكم
اذا اراد حمايه بيل قرود على روسيا ان تحت
الخارجيه
يعني هذا سقف عالي جدا
وبالتالي هل هو يعني هذا تصريح من حاكم
وقد يكون تحت تاثير الضغط او تحت تاثير
التداعيات لكن هل الجيش الروسي قادر على
ذلك الجيش الروسي يستعد الان لاستقبال
هجوم وليس لتوسيع دائره دائره العمليات
الان من المتوقع جدا
حال تنفيذ اي ضربه داخل الجغرافيا الروسيه
على اي هدف وموسفات نفط قاعده انجلز غيرها
ان يكون هناك رد وكلنا نتذكر الجميع يتذكر
عندما تم مهاجمه جسر كرش تمت في اليوم
التالي خلال 24 ساعه توجيه اكبر هجمه
صاروخيه منذ بدء الحرب انتقاما واثباتا
للقدره فبالتالي لا تزال لا يزال الجيش
الروسي لديهم في هذه الحاله دكتور
فايز الدويري في اطار رد على ما جرى في
بيل جرود اما ان ما يجري اليوم وجرب في
الايام الماضيه هو مقدمه لشيء ما لعمل
روسي عسكري روسي هجوم روسي او على الاقل
في اطار محاولات روسيا احباط الهجوم
المضاده لاوكراني
يا سيدي عمليه تنفيذ هذه الضرب هي تخدم
كافه الاتجاهات
ردا على تنفيذ العمليه الارضيه في بيل
قرود تاتي
القدرات الهجوميه الكامله للقوات التي تم
تحضيرها عندما يتم انتقاء الاهداف من وجهه
نظر استراتيجيه عندما انا كمخطط عمل في
هيئه الاركان يكون لدي توجهات سياسيه ولدي
معطيات استراتيجيه ومعطيات ميدانيه الان
اضع اولويه هذه لاهداف وتكون الاولويه
للاهداف ذات التاثير المشترك بمعنى انها
ستكون ضمن اطار الرد لارضاء القاعده
الشعبيه والشعب الروسي ان لدى الجيش
الروسي لا يزال رقم اثنين في العالم منها
اضعاف القدره الهجوميه ومنها الحاق
الاضرار باهظه سواء استراتيجيا او
اقتصاديا اذا دعني اقول اولويه الاهداف
تكون
متدرجه حسب اهميه هذا الهدف في ابعاده
السياسيه والاستراتيجيه والاقتصاديه
والعسكريه
ولكن الرسائل من وراء استهداف او اعاده
استهداف العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف من جديد
بهذا الزخم لاول مره منذ بدايه هذه الحرب
على اوكرانيا
يعني في التخطيط الاستراتيجي وفي اعداد
تقدير الموقف الاستراتيجي هناك نقاط
وعلامات فارقه اهمها تحديد مراكز الثقل
والنقاط والمناطق الحاسمه وهذا هو في اطار
العلم العسكري والاستراتيجي اولا النقاط
المراكز الثقل هي المراكز التي لها اذا ما
تم مهاجمتها لها امتدادات انعكاسات في
البعد السياسي والاستراتيجي والاقتصادي
والعسكري ننزل الى الطبقه الثانيه من
الاهداف وهي ما يسمى بالنقاط او المناطق
الحاسمه وهذه امام الحالات تاثيره ينحصر
في الاطار العسكري اكثر منه في الاطار
السياسي والاقتصادي والاستراتيجي لهذا
السبب عندما نتحدث عن العاصمه نتحدث عن
مركز الثقل الاستراتيجي رقم واحد في كافه
دول العالم
القياده السياسيه
كنا بدانا الحديث عن القابلين الاستمرار
تحدثت عن المخزون الروسي من الصواريخ
وبدات بالحديث عن
المخزون الاوكراني من المضادات المضادات
الدفاع الجوي تحدثت عن بطاريتين فقط
اذا استمر هطوله صواريخ بهذا المعدل على
كيف ما قدره بطاريتين فقط
على التصدي لها بجانب
العدد الكبير ايضا من المسيرات التي
تستهدف العاصمه الاوكرانيه
لم يتم الحديث عن استخدامها خلال 48 ساعه
الماضيه انا لم اسمع
المقابل هناك اكثر من 14 نظام دفاع جوي
الان موجود داخل اوكرانيا من مختلف الدول
الاوروبيه يبدا في
ومن ثم مرورا بنا حتى يصل الى صواريخ
ستنجر حوالي 14 15 نظام دفاع جوي زودت به
اوكرانيا خلال 15 شهر الماضيه هذا اذا
دعني اقول صواريخ الباتريوت سيتم من حيث
الذخيره لهذا السبب قد يلجا قد يلجا
المخطط
والمسؤول في هيئه ركن الدفاع الجوي الى
التقنين القاتل في استخدام هذه الصواريخ
والاكتفاء بالبدائل المتاحه بدءا لانه
طائرات شاهد يمكن التعامل معها
باسلحه مقاومه الطيران التقليديه الرشاشات
الرباعيه الرشاشات الثنائيه رشاش 7.2 ملم
وغير ذلك ستتوقف عن استخدام الصواريخ ليس
فقط باتيوس وليس وليس حتى السنجر انما اذا
استمرت هذه الكثافه من الهجمات سنجد
اختلافا
في قضيه التصدي والاعتماد على الاسلحه
التقليديه لان المخزونات الغربيه مرهقه
سواه الدفاع الجوي او في اعداد الدبابات
او في قنابل المدفعيه قبل الثمانيه ساعه
كان الحديث عن
الطلب الامريكي من كوريا الجنوبيه ان ترسل
مليون قذيفه وبالتالي هذا الامر على ما
يدل طلبه اخذتهم من المستودعات في اسرائيل
اخذت من مخزونات الخط الثاني ومخزونات
الخط الثالث والكل يتحدث ان وقود الحرب في
اوكرانيا واليه استخدام الافراط فاستخدام
الذخيره كبير جدا ولا تستطيع المصانع
مواكبه ذلك
اللواء فايز الدويري الخبراء العسكريون
توقعوا وانت منهم بحاله التصعيد وتطور
الامور ربما الى هذا الحد وربما سيناريو
ابعد من ذلك على المستوى العسكري ماذا عن
الجانب
الاوكراني هل كان الاوكران يتوقعون ان
تتطور الامور الى هذه الحاله من التصعيد
واذا كانوا كذلك فعلى ماذا يعوضه
يعني دعيني اقول كلا الجانبين لم يتوقع
ذلك الجانب الروسي في قراءه الاستراتيجيه
الحد الاقصى للعمليات العسكريه 14 يوم
وهذا تم الحديث عنه من سنوات انا تحدثت
وغيري تحدث وحتى سي اي ووزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه وكانت نوع من خداع الرئيس
بوتين واهامه بان كما يقال
وبالتالي
ابحث اوفيستون وبالتالي لم يتوقع الجيش
الروسي ان
يغوص في الوحل الاوكراني لهذا الفتره من
الزمن